and it's good
efe
i
min
[Laughter]
the navy teams team
I have 2
waterfield just had white
in the distribution how man can
destroy
himself d yes yes
d
[Laughter]
i
way
[Applause]
the way
up
in the  pressure drop and this flex
activity record in ordes curve ex
goal ping the census must be neglected
and very well
for others
in your home 2
on the web
and sometimes
the best defenders in the league
vicente guaita com
you are going to control me
h
seibert notifications
looking for april
h from now
on
for him
buckles
does not want anything
with war
in the 1st
at 36
the people
in him
ah
or not
in writing
suffer in writing
from him
in sex
in a month
efe
chips
charles  bolden had to build
d